Hey youtubers it's Charlie and Disney is bringing
Rebels to Comic Con in a couple weeks so I
wanted to do a bonus video. This is going
to be a breakdown of all the characters and
how Rebels is going to fit in with the movies.
Normally my Star Wars bonus videos are movie
related, but there really isn't a whole lot
of new stuff happening with it and Episode
7 will not be at comic con.
Hello any new people, if you're finding me
for the first time I'm doing bonus Rebels
videos till season 1 gets here. Be sure to
subscribe to get everything. I'll probably
combine all those videos in my big Star Wars
playlist. There's a link for that in the description.
First Big Question When Can We Watch Rebels
Episodes?
They still haven't announced a premiere date,
but they'll probably say what it is during
their comic con panel. All we know is that
it's coming in the Fall, which means September
or October. And I'm betting on October. Most
tv shows in general debut between that last
week in September and the Middle of October.
I probably won't make it to the Rebels panel,
but I will still be doing a Star Wars giveaway
that week.
Next big Question, How do I enter the giveaway
and what do I win?
All the comic con giveaways I do are the same,
you can enter all of them. All you have to
do is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on the different videos I'll post next week.
Because I might not get another new Rebels
video out I'm just going to include comments
on this video as entries in the Rebels Giveaway.
I'll just be picking one random subscriber
from these comments in about two weeks and
you'll win an action figure. And yes, it is
open to international people, but you guys
will probably just win paypal.
It's basically just like any other giveaway
I do for everything else.
Next Big Question, Where does Rebels Fit in
the new Star Wars Movie Canon?
In case you hadn't heard, yes it is canon,
so characters developed on Rebels will exist
inside the movie universe, even if you never
see them. This is in contrast to most of the
expanded universe, which isn't considered
canon anymore.
The episodes will take place between the events
of Revenge of The Sith and A New Hope, so
episodes 3 and 4. Technically it's closer
to episode 4. It takes place like 5 years
before Episode 4. So that means Luke Skywalker
and Leia are about 11 years old. I got that
number just because they're twins and he was
about 16 at the beginning of episode 4.
You see what they're doing, they're basically
engineering it so that the show runs for five
seasons and ends with the events that set
off Episode 4. So ideally you should imagine
the final moments of Rebels happening in the
moments before Darth Vader's Star Destroyer
chases Princess Leia's Corellian Corvette
in orbit of Tatooine.
That actually makes me wonder if the show
is somehow going to start with a similar situation
to bookend the series.
Episode 7 is starting on Tatooine, or at least
the first parts of the movie are. That's one
of the first locations they shot footage on
with the cast. You can't do a Star Wars show
without visiting Tatooine at some point.
And what's going to happen if the show runs
for six or seven seasons or longer?
Clone Wars went for six seasons, so Rebels
could totally do the same thing. Plus it's
airing on a Network that Disney owns. So it's
cheaper for them in the end. They don't have
to pay license fees to Cartoon Network. So
it's easier for them to keep it in production.
I know everyone is asking if we're going to
see Original Trilogy Characters on the show.
The answer is yes, but not exactly the way
you think.
The biggest person people have been asking
me about is Asoka. In case you forgot, at
the end of Clone Wars Season 5 she left the
Jedi Order and we didn't see her again until
she appeared in Season 6. Yoda saw her dead
in a possible future, lying next to Mace Windu.
It was just a vision and Dave Filoni who's
in charge of the series said that he wants
to include her in Rebels some how. She'd be
in her 20s or 30s by the time the show starts.
Ashley Eckstein, the actress that voiced her
confirmed that she survived Order 66. So Asoka
could totally show up, plus there's the whole
force spirit twist. Although if they do use
her, I think it will be flesh and blood Asoka.
James Arnold Taylor who voiced Obi-Wan Kenobi
on Clone Wars is also rumored to be coming
back for cameos.
The other big Original cast member coming
back is Billy Dee Williams as Lando Calrissian.
This is a huge deal and I can't wait to see
him. Simon Kinberg is writing the series and
he didn't confirm what Lando would be doing
in Rebels or how many episodes he'd be in,
but they'll probably tease that at comic con.
And the other Original Cast Members that will
come back.
Kinberg also said there would be more Movie
Actors coming back to voice cameo roles, but
we don't know who. I'm hoping since Mark Hamill
is such a prolific voice actor, he comes back
in some way. Harrison Ford and Carrie Fisher
aren't super huge on reprising their roles
in other non-movie media.
Like on Family Guy, Seth MacFarlane said that
when they did the Star Wars parody episodes.
Carrie Fisher only participated because she
already played the Angela character and they
put Angela in the episodes. Otherwise she
wouldn't have done them.
So other Original Trilogy people that could
return would be Anthony Daniels for 3PO and
James Earl Jones as Vader. Disney hasn't said
Vader or no Vader, but he's supposedly going
to have a small cameo. The main villain is
the Inquisitor. He'll be the force sensitive
Vader Analog chasing the last of the Jedi
down.
The show is named Rebels and it's about the
Rebellion. Who are they at this point in the
The show is about the early days of the Rebellion,
so it's more of an idea in the heads of a
bunch of troublemakers and dissident politicians
than the giant fleet we see in the Original
Trilogy.
The main cast is the crew of the Corellian
VCX-100 modified freighter Ghost. It's like
a smaller version of the Millenium Falcon.
Disney really wants people to watch this so
they're promoting the hell out of it, which
is awesome. They've released details on all
of the characters except the original trilogy
surprise cameos. That's mostly just because
they never know who's going to come back till
contracts are signed and scripts are written.
It's a whole complicated thing.
The heroes are basically like a prequel version
of Luke Skywalker's Millenium Falcon team
in episode 4. Here's a breakdown of the main
cast and the original Star Wars character
they represent.
There's former Jedi Kanan Jarrus. He's being
voiced by Freddie Prinze Jr. Think of him
as a burnt out version of Obi-Wan Kenobi.
Why is he a former Jedi?
During episode 3 revenge of the sith when
order 66 went out he was still a padawan.
So he never fully finished his Jedi Training.
He's a lot like Luke during Empire Strikes
Back. He has skills, but he lacks some of
the maturity Jedi gain after facing an ultimate
challenge.
The Inquisitor character, who's going to be
voiced by Jason Isaacs. He's the Darth Vader
of the show. Even though the actual Vader
character might cameo. If you've read any
of the expanded universe material. The Inquisitorius
was a branch of the Imperial Intelligence
community led by Force Sensitive Dark Side
agents.
They weren't full on Jedi but they did have
the ability to sense other Force Users. Which
is part of the reason the Emperor used them
to hunt down Jedi.
Because the expanded universe is being tucked
away in a closet. The Rebels show is simplifying
things and just making it a one person operation
with many regular Imperial Troops at his command.
They're just calling him The Inquisitor for
now, but they'll probably reveal his true
name on the show.
He is wearing Sith tech, so I'm curious to
see how they explain the rule of two and if
he's Vader's apprentice or the Emperor's.
He'll probably intersect with the crew of
the Ghost because of Jedi Kanan and the other
force sensitive character traveling with them,
Ezra Bridger. He's being voiced by Taylor
Gray. He's like a mixture of Asoka and Luke
Skywalker. He's got Asoka's mouth but looks
more like Luke.
He grew up on the streets who had to learn
to steal to survive. Before Jedi Kanan finds
him he used the force unknowingly to get out
of dangerous situations.
He lives in the Outer Rim Territories, which
is about as far as you can get from Coruscant
if you wanted to hide in the charted areas
of the galaxy.
The crew of the Ghost will be traveling to
a lot of familiar planets on the show, but
because they're trying to evade the empire,
they'll probably spend a lot of time in the
galactic rim.
Jedi Kanan will be mentoring Ezra in the ways
of the Jedi over the course of the show. But
remember, Kanan isn't a full Jedi himself
which might have some interesting consequences.
Hera Syndulla is the Twilek Pilot and Owner
of the Ghost. She's being voiced by Vanessa
Marshall. I guess you could say she's the
scoundrel of the crew. But she doesn't come
off as a dirtbag or anything. So think of
her as the Han Solo of the team. She actually
stole the Ghost, so they're kind of paying
homage to the questionable ownership of the
Millenium Falcon.
Technically Han won it in a card game from
Lando fair and square. But I think it was
implied that he may have cheated Lando. Both
Lando and Han cheat at cards, so you could
debate cheating a cheater is fair.
Syndulla is the pilot, but Jedi Kanan is the
leader of the group. She is supposed to mentor
the mandalorian character Sabine Wren.
She's being voiced by Tiya Sircar. Think of
her as like the weapons expert part of Chewbacca
in the body of a female humanoid. They haven't
revealed a lot about her heritage as a mandalorian,
but since the expanded universe is out. Forget
what you know about the Mandalorian Warrior
Race.
They're doing this weird graffiti thing on
the show where they tag a lot of stuff wherever
they go with the Rebel Alliance insignia.
She's the graffiti artist. I don't know why
they're making this a thing. Maybe because
they think little kids will think graffiti
is hip and edgy.
Then there's a Zeb character who's being voiced
by Steve Blum, you may remember him as the
voice of Amon on Legend of Korra or the voice
of Spike on Cowboy Bebop. He's the real Chewbacca
of the crew, the big guy. He's a Lasat, which
is a race they created for Rebels specifically.
It was based on the original Ralph McQuarrie
designs for Chewbacca and the Wookie Race.
The have an astromech droid called Chopper,
he's going to be a more sarcastic version
of R2, but just like R2, he'll be bailing
the crew of the Ghost out of trouble on a
regular basis.
The other big new character the show just
revealed is one of the villains called Agent
Kallus. He's being voiced by David Oyelowo.
He's going to be the Inquisitor's second in
command. He doesn't seem like he has the austere
shakesperean look of Grand Moff Tarkin, so
I'm going to think of him as General Veers
for now.
Interesting fact. Julian Glover played Veers
in the original trilogy. He's on Game of Thrones
right now playing Maester Pycelle. He was
also in Indiana Jones and the Last Crusade
as the main villain.
Agent Kallus is supposed to have something
in common with the Zeb character, their weapons
are similar to each other. So I'm wondering
if they have history together.
But that's basically it for now. They'll probably
screen some footage from the first episode
at comic con. I don't think I'm going to make
it to the panel but if they reveal anything
big I'll be sure to do a video.
My next Star Wars video will be my favorite
Expanded Universe characters that I want the
show to bring back. Be sure to subscribe to
get it. It's way easier for them to bring
characters back on TV than it is in the movies.
Remember, Comic Con Star Wars giveaway starts
now. More Star Wars Linkage in the description.
Right now click here to learn all about the
new Jedi and Sith characters in Episode 7
and click here to learn about the rest of
the cast.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
high fives!